good day welcome everyone i'm jack van
horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to our
final in this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
i am delighted to have our final speaker
in this series today
dr giorgio escoli from george mason
university
he earned his bachelor of science degree
in chemistry and in physics from scuella
normale superiore
uh in pisa italy he earned a master's
degree in chemistry and biochemistry
from pisa university
and his phd in biochemistry and
neuroscience
also from escuela normale superiore in
pisa
dr scoli has dedicated his career to
advancements in biochemistry and
neuroscience he investigates protein
structure and binding
in the nervous system he is the founding
director of the center for neural
informatics structures and plasticity
at the krasnow institute for advanced
study his laboratory uses experimental
data computational modeling
modern informatics infrastructures to
address fundamental and open questions
in the neurosciences he is specifically
interested in the description and
generation of neuronal morphometry and
connectivity and the structure and
activity and function
of neural circuits in the long term he
seeks to create large-scale
anatomically plausible neural networks
to model entire portions
of the mammalian brain and in the long
term
also in the long term he has
interest in cellular representations and
model of memory as well as
consciousness he's published in numerous
journals including the journal of
neuroscience proceedings of the national
academy of science neuron and nature
reviews neuroscience and amongst other
important roles
dr escoly is the founding
editor-in-chief of the journal
neuroinformatics
the leading periodical focused at the
intersection of the brain and
computational sciences
and is also on the editorial board of
several other international journals he
also serves as an advisory board member
to many scientific organizations and is
the past president
of the potomac chapter of the society
for neuroscience and he's contributed
much to the establishment of the fields
of computational neural anatomy and to
neuroinformatics
his talk today is entitled neuron
morphometry or excuse me morphology
connectivity and classification
and as always we are streaming this
lecture live for recording via youtube
and if you're watching via youtube thank
you so much for joining us once again
and also our specially selected 2020
2021 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr oskoli by the chat feature in
their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf at the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture
um and with that giorgio thank you so
much for being our last
uh seminar speaker we really really
appreciate it we are super excited to
hear your presentation
thank you very much jack for the very
very kind introduction i'm very happy to
be here
with you all today and my goal is to
tell you a story that started
many years ago precisely in 2005
in a small town in spain called patilia
de arragona
which is the birth city of
santiago ramonica hal considered
by many of the founding fathers the
father of a modern neuroscientist
and the reason that the story starts in
his birthdown
is that uh in 2005 there was a gathering
of a number of leading scientists from
all around the world
to try and come to a consensus on the
classification of
neuron types in the mammalian brain
and classifying neuron types uh the goal
of that
endeavor was really to start putting
together the parts list
to then assemble circuits and there were
many lines of thoughts
uh one that said that we should look at
the molecular
uh footprint of the cells and the
expression or what is now known as a
transcriptomics
since that was where many data were
beginning to be
accumulated another line of thought was
to consider
the physiology or the activity which is
the firing pattern
of the brain cells because that's
ultimately what commands the activity
and therefore the function of circuits
and yet a third line of thought was that
we should look at the connectivity of
the circuit since
uh the connectivity is really what
allows
uh and constrain activity to flow in the
circuit
and the meeting was optimistically
organized over the course of five days
and at the end of the first day
the only consensus that was reached was
that it would be impossible to reach a
consensus
and part of the reason for that is that
people who really speak in different
languages
what one was calling a tomato somebody
else was calling a potato
it was not just a matter of
pronunciation it was actually a matter
of
using different terms for the same
concept
and the same term for different concepts
so we quickly pivoted
to a very different more realistic and
practical goal
which was to create a nomenclature of
features to describe
nerve cells and that's been widely used
uh since then but the question of
classification of neurons
remains and uh the goal of defining
neuron types by their morphological
physiological and molecular properties
have remained since that 2005 a very
important goal for the whole community
of neuroscience
and personally one of the ways
i like to think of it being trained in
chemistry is to think of the periodic
table of the elements
and to dream of creating a periodic
table of the neurons
now the periodic table of the elements
of course is what allows us to predict
the reactivity
of atomic constituents of molecules so
we can know for example
that elements that are on the left-hand
side for example in the first
column of the table have a balance of
one and they tend to give away one
electron
and elements that tend to uh that that
belong to the
uh second to last column on the right uh
also have a balance of one but they tend
to gain an electron
so it's a match made in heaven if we
take one of the elements from
this column here combining with one of
the elements with this column and so for
example
if you combine sodium and chloride you
get sea salt which is
one of the most abundant molecules but
of course
we know today that the key
aspect of the elements that determines
the position
of these elements in this very orderly
uh
organization is the atomic number uh but
then again there are many other aspects
that could in principle and in theory uh
if you did not know better
um determine uh organizations of these
of these elements for example why
shouldn't we organize them by melting
point
or by uh electronegativity for example
or even alphabetically by by full name
for example
and uh it's very interesting to know
that when mandela ef
first organized the atomic
table of the elements in 1869
the atomic number didn't exist because
the atomic number is the number of
protons
in the nucleus and proton had not been
discovered yet
as a particle so mandela did the next
best thing which was to organize that
with what he could measure which was
atomic mass
and he was very lucky because the atomic
mass which is the number of protons
plus the number of neutrons in the
nucleus tends to be approximately twice
that
the atomic number so he got lucky but
there are deviations
uh there are uh uh deviations from this
rule
and very interestingly when the laf
tried to correct those and said there
are mistakes in the experimental
uh measurement of the atomic mass there
were no mistakes
but simply the the atomic number had to
be brought into the picture
and very interestingly also based on the
regularity of this periodicity
when dialect predicted the existence of
several elements that were later
discovered but what is even more
interesting
is to take a look at mendeleev's
original handwritten notes
which are conserved at the russian
academy of science in moscow
and you can see here that there are many
scribbles
many attempts and errors and
right overs and so forth so
i like to think that in neuroscience
these days we are at this stage here we
are scrambling
and searching for possible regularities
in the organization of the neurons and
we hope to get to this point
where we're going to see enough to
organize our data in a viable and
functional way
and this could lead to the discovery of
the next atomic number
uh for neuroscience so that was my uh
a brief introduction and i'll jump right
into the the principle that i would like
to propose
and walk you with uh today in the next
20 25 minutes or so
which is that the uh regional
connectivity
sorry the regional laminar location of
the
trees that come out of the cell body in
the neurons which are the axons and the
dendrites
is the defining feature of neuron types
and the reason for that is that axons
constitute the output of the neurons and
dendrites constitute the inputs of the
neurons
and therefore the location of the axons
and the dendrites
in brain space strongly constrains if
not fully determines
network connectivity and please do ask
questions i did ask
jack to feel free to interrupt me uh
with questions i do like to
answer doubts and offer clarifications
uh during the course of my talk so
please
feel free to type your questions in the
chat and jack do do interrupt me
if there are questions that i can answer
um meanwhile
so can we just take this very simple
idea
of simply say where the axons of the
neuron are
in a brain location and where the
dendrites of a neuron are
and simply define the identity of a
neuron based on those characteristics
that's a question right it's a
hypothesis so that might seem like a
little bit too simple
right and is it simple really so we can
take
the human brain and uh as a cartoon
characterization divided just in the
four lobes that you find
in the first chapter of an anatomy book
right the frontal lobe the periatal lobe
the occipital lobe and the temporal lobe
and then of course you have a right hand
side and left hand side
and so that's basically just a two by
two by two characterization it's this
the easiest and simplest anatomical
personalization
you can do of a three-dimensional object
it's binary on each of the three
dimensions
right so i don't know if you ever heard
the
idiom of mathematicians trying to
approximate
complex problems with simplifications to
make them analytic and they say
you cannot have a spherical cow right
and this is my cubic brain it's my
version of the spherical cow
so let's pretend that we only have eight
possible locations in the brain
of course in reality we have many more
and that means that
if you take a maximum of a neuron the
action can be
in any combinations of these eight
locations so you have a
eight dimensional binary vector where
the axon can be
in any one location or not and the same
for the dendrite you have an eight
dimensional binary vector for the
dendrites so for example this would be
the identity of a given neuron in the
space right where the axon is
in the second third fourth seventh and
eighth location
and the dendrites in the third fourth
fifth sixth sorry
fourth fifth sixth and seventh location
i counted from zero sorry so if we do
that
we actually immediately even from a two
by two by two percentation
we come out with 65
000 possible identities right
65 000 possible neuron types and of
course
if you're interested in connections in
how many neurons can connect to
how many other neurons you can do the
arithmetics it's an interesting
calculations
but it turns out to be approximately 3.8
billion
distinct types of connections and what i
mean by types of connections is a
connection determined by a presynaptic
neuron
and a postsynaptic neuron type and that
is just out of a two by two by two cube
now in practice the brain is not made
out of
a two by two by two box uh in in the
typical brain atlases there are at least
a thousand distinct regions
that are that are recognized and that's
true in mammalian brains generally
speaking
in the human brain and of course jack
himself has been a pioneer in this field
i tend to work mostly with
mouse data but mouse analysis also have
of the order of a thousand distinct
regions
so if you do the math with a thousand
dimensional vector instead of an eight
dimensional vector
the theoretically possible number of
neuron types is far greater
than the total number of individual
neurons in any
organism if you count for all the
animals put together
so this is to say that this is not it's
a very simple conceptual
framework but it's actually a very very
very informative
framework so we decided to run with it
and we tried to
do this exercise for my favorite brain
region which is the hippocampus
i tend to like the hippocampus for two
different reasons one is that it's very
recognizable
in the brain of all mammals this is a
rat brain
but it's also equally recognizable in in
the mouse brain and of course in the
human brain
uh and it can be a particulated very
clearly
in functional regions
but the second reason that i very much
like the hippocampus is that
the hippocampus underlies functions that
are very near and dear me including
episodic memory autobiographic memory
and first person perspective
representations of memories so these are
memories that have you in the center of
attention
and uh allow for so to speak mental
travel
time and space travel where you can
navigate back in the eye of your mind
to maybe 10 years ago
and your birthday that you celebrate it
with your family
or maybe even as recent and as this
morning and what you had
for breakfast this morning so uh
we we took this region that we wanted to
create computational models of and we
started looking for evidence of neurons
that were represented
as the distributions of their dendrites
and axons in this case for example this
is a beautiful
neuronal representation from the thomson
lab
in the uk and the interpretation of the
neurons in this area
ca2 which is approximately here in the
hippocampus
and it has dendrites that cross all the
layers
of this region and axons that are
largely
limited to this layer the stratum
pyramidal
and it turns out that this type of
representation is actually very typical
so this is a summary of all the neurons
of the internal cortex which is the part
of the neocortex
that interfaces the hippocampus with the
rest of the brain
and in the summer you can pretty much
see the same which is in black you see
the dendrites
and you can see for each neuron type
where the dendrites are in the layers of
the internal cortex
and in red you see the axon and you can
say which layers
the axons invade in the internal cortex
so we started collecting this
information approximately 10 years ago
and it took us about
three and a half years of mining the
literature
we mined actually close to 10 000
articles parsing through the information
and organize that into a relational
database
and this is a graphical representation
of this it's a little complex matrix so
let me walk you through it
each row in this matrix is a neuron type
for example this is a granule cell which
is a famous neuron type in the dental
jars which is the first
region of the hippocampus and each
column is
a particular atomic location like the
layer
in a given region and when you see uh
white it means that there is no presence
of the neuron type in that region
when you see red or if you're color
blind horizontal striping that's axonal
presence
in that region when you see blue
or vertical striping it means that there
is dendritic region
dendritic presence and when you see
purple or crisscross both vertical and
horizontal
that means that both the axons and the
dendrites and remember axon means output
dendrites means input so both the output
and the inputs or both the axons and the
dendrites
of a given neuron type are in that
region so for example the granule cell
is defined
in this framework as a neuron type that
has dendrites
in the first three layers of the dental
jars the outer and inner molecular layer
and the granular layer the axon in the
hylus of the dental jars and the axons
in the lucidum
pyramidal and orient layer of ca3
and by doing that you can start
basically collecting all information
independent of how neurons are called
and name which is as i pointed out
earlier
very very diverse than non-uniform and
we created this
database called the hippocamp as in all
things
cellular hippocampus and so the the
framework the anatomica framework was
done for us by many anatomists
uh before our time there are 26 known
sub-regions in the hippocampus
we uh uh we pass now the mark of 100
neurons we have
more than 120 neurons annotated um
when we started released the first
version we had more than 5000 references
now we actually passed the mark
of 10 000 references as we continue to
layer information
uh on this uh on this region and we uh
continue to annotate not just the
location of the dendrites and the axons
but also the target specificity of the
neurons
for example if i would target pyramidal
or interneuron
or even a subcellular location of the
synaptic connections
and also additional information like
molecular markers
these are very famous molecules that can
be expressed or not expressed in given
neurons
for example calcium binding proteins
like pervalidum
parvalbumin calbindin and carotene
uh peptides like vip
npy cck and somatostatin and enzyme like
and nosh and then biophysics which
included
spiking patterns passive properties and
more
so i'm going to provide you a little bit
of examples with that but first let me
explain what we
mean when we say we annotated the
presence of an axon or a dendrite
in a given layer what i mean is actually
exactly that
right we number all the references we
number all the pieces of evidence
and for every piece of evidence we have
the exact
bibliographic citation including the
excerpt
of why we think that the knowledge
conclusion of that work
supports the identity the definition of
the neuron
that reflects its identity so this is an
example of the notation of the
biophysics of the neurons
with many membrane properties such as
the
input output relationship the resting
potential the input resistance the time
constants etc
and this is an example of what the
evidence looks like we need to
link this information to the presence of
axons and dendrites so
we start from the morphology of the
neuron and then people
measure firing activity with electrodes
in these neurons
and they can go down to the sub
threshold activity the sub threshold
is what is used to measure in this case
uh the vi curve
which is the voltage versus current
injection this is hyper polarizing
current this is
depolarizing current and the slope of
that line basically
giorgio i think you have somehow muted
yourself very interesting can you hear
me now
yes we can thanks ah when uh for how
many seconds or i hope not minute it was
like
just about maybe slightly more than five
seconds all right okay it's probably
that uh
through some some clicking around i do
not see the controls of zoom so probably
clicking on the slides and pointing to
the slides i accidentally muted myself
but anyway this slide shows the
collection and collation of biophysical
information for neuron properties and
from there we go to
computational modeling very quickly
because we can see not just the
membrane properties of the neurons but
also the firing activity of the neurons
those are typically recorded
in laboratories all around the world and
are published and we can take that
information and fit dynamical system
models
and if we have time i'll show you an
example of those live
but basically computational models based
on differential equations
uh that are able to reproduce the
activity of the neurons as recorded
uh in in laboratories and so that
information is also layered in
uh onto the identity of the cells and
into the knowledge base
and last but not least of course the
molecular phenotype so
we have more and more of this in the
community so we have expression patterns
but you have to be careful how you
interpret expression patterns because
people can measure different things when
they talk about molecular expression
they might be measuring a protein or
they might measuring a gene
and where the protein expressed in the
neuron is very important because the
genes
are always in the nucleus which is in
the cell body but the proteins can be in
the axons or in the dendrites or the
synapse level
and that provides very important
information as to what the roles
of those proteins are and we annotate
all of that information for at this
point
hundreds of molecular markers
so the most important aspect of this
work is that because the neural identity
is linked to the presence of dendrites
and axons
and remember the dendrites are the
inputs and the
axons are the outputs of the neurons you
can create a connectivity matrix
just by saying where the ones in those
vectors
are and when the zeros are you can say
if the
axon of a given neuron shares some
anatomical space with the dendrite of
the other neuron
you can see that there is a potential
connection there and so you can create a
complete circuit diagram in this case
created in the form of a connectivity
matrix where in this case again white
box means that there is no connection
between the presynaptic neuron as a row
and the postsynaptic neuron as a column
and if you see a black box it means that
there is a connection that we know to be
excitatory because we know the
neurotransmitter
released by the presynaptic neuron is
glutamate and if you see a gray box we
know that there is a connection that is
inhibitory
because we know that the
neurotransmitter released by the
presynaptic neuron
is gaba
and so you can actually start playing
with that in a quantitative
fashion when you have a lot of data it's
hard to visualize it all together but
you can start by local circuits so in
this case the denta gyrus is one part of
the hippocampus
there are you know a reasonable number
of neuron types that are known
and these are the four layers of the
dental jars
and i'm representing on this wall of the
room
the axons in red and on this wall of the
room
the dendrites in blue and so you can now
imagine seeing if i'm interested in this
particular presynaptic neurontide the
semilunar granule cell
and this particular neuron type the
outer molecular
layer cell i want to know if they
connect and you can see that there is in
fact connections
as a matter of fact in multiple regions
and
you can even see that in the space
lives the space of anatomy or the atlas
of the brain
and in this particular case we know that
for example
the location in which the uh
semiduna granule cells and the outer
molecular
layer cells could make a connection
and you can actually go in and
reconstruct those neurons
and in this particular case this is a
actual tracings of
the similar granule cell down here
and the outer molecular layer cell up
here and the locations in which the
axons of one
can make contact with the dendrite of
the other
and the beautiful aspect of this is that
you can even measure
not just that they can in principle make
contacts but what is the probability
that any two cells
make contacts which is based on the
lengths of the axons in a given layer
and the length of the dendrites on a
given layer
and the volumes of the layers you can
actually do a little bit of arithmetic
and compute the probability that they
would in fact get in touch with each
other with the synapse
so the way that it works is like this
you start from the reconstructions which
can be 2d or 3d
and then you do analysis which is
basically computational geometry where
you look at
the linear density of these filaments in
space
and you can even compute the distances
uh based on the same computational
uh geometry and you can calculate the
probability
that a particular axonal
branch would fall into the proximity of
a dendritic branch it could happen even
more
than once and so you can calculate both
the probability that two neurons would
get in touch but also the number of
typical
contacts that they would make and then
you can store the results again in a
database
and do that for all pairs of neurons
which are many thousands
and when you do that you basically
end up with a micro circuit for each and
every cell in the knowledge base
where you can get all the inputs and all
the outputs of the cells
in a quantitative fashion so you have
both probabilities number of contacts
distances along the axons and distances
along the dendrites and these are all
very very key elements
to then simulate realistically the
circuit
for the given brain function and
remember we have the input output
relationship of the neurons
and we have the spiking dynamics of the
neurons that are also simulated
so this is a summary of what we've done
right what i like to think of a periodic
table of in this case hippocampal
neurons but you can really do that
for many different brain regions so
we're using the axonal and dendritic
valance so to speak the atomic number
which is really more like an atomic mass
at this point you know it's an
approximation
of what we are really seeking which is
synaptic connectivity
the parcels the subregions or the layers
are
the dimensions of the space so mendeleev
was lucky
and could solve his problem in the late
1800s because the space of atomic
reactivity
in chemistry is single dimensional you
just have a single scalar
an integer as a matter of fact that
defines the reactivity
of all elements the brain is a complex
space and you can make connections in
many different parcels or neuropills in
the brain
and therefore the periodic table of
neurons is a high dimensional
organization not a single dimensional
organization
we complement that circuitry information
with molecular and membrane biophysics
data and we then quantify the firing
patterns
we use a particular brand of modeling
called isikevich models which are very
computationally efficient
and analytically tractable then we
calculate the connection probability and
the number of contacts starting from the
same data
and we release all the informations
online on the web at hippocampum.org so
both
machines and human users can retrieve
this information and incorporate that
in computational models or to design
better experiments or to do
meta-analysis
quantitative data science and so forth
so what is uh what is coming soon
starting from this framework
well lots is brewing the first thing is
that we are actually about to release
a huge component of the knowledge base
having to do with synaptic signals or
communication
uh in the system so we have collated
already
all the amplitude kinetics and
short-term plasticity
for all the pairs of neuron types that
are known
or thought to make connections in
hippocampus we already posted the raw
data
the tricky part is to normalize it so we
found a very nice
innovative way to normalize the data the
paper was submitted
as recently as last week so it's
currently under review
and we hope to be able to post those
data very soon as well
we're also completing the population
counts
of every neuron type so that's uh the
census right you want to know how many
granular cells there are
how many basket cells there are and so
forth not just that they are there
and lastly we're putting together a
complementary knowledge base
of network functions that can be
implemented by spiking models
so we know that hippocampus is involved
in the consolidation of
autobiographic episodic memory but we
also know for example the hippocampus is
involved in the representation
of space and navigation and in many
other types
of function also dysfunction for example
the hippocampus is a pivotal region in
memory disorders like alzheimer's
disease but also neurological disorder
disorders very common like stroke and
epilepsy
these are all for different reasons
reasons uh
centered very much in the hippocampal
formation
and if we wanted to create a large scale
model we would be well positioned for
that
we have 120 neuron types each neuron
type typically
invades three to four different
anatomical areas so
you would have to take those into
account so each will be
approximately 400 each network would be
about 400 compartments to simulate
and that boils down to approximately 10
000 parameters and very interestingly
this is a type of simulation that runs
very
in a very friendly way on gpus graphical
processing units
i have to thank my children and many
other
billions of people on the planet who
enjoy playing video games because that
has pushed the industry of entertainment
to to incredible heights and that has in
fact facilitated
the technological developments that we
can all enjoy as researchers and i can
buy
a reasonably priced computer today that
could do the kinds of things that ibm
could only dream to do with their super
computers
uh maybe 20 years ago and so we actually
can do a real scale real time
simulations of the entire hippocampal
formation on our
supercomputers on campus
and this is just an eye candy it's an
example of
one such network put together even if it
seems
pretty complex there are only four
neurons designed here
in different colors uh one for each of
the stations of the hippocampus the
dental gyro c3c1
and the internal cortex and i'm showing
them rotating them so you see them in
their own
spatial complexity most of the branching
that you see there is axons
because the axons do most of their
travel
in the network the dendrites are tend to
stay local
and to integrate information
and i'll give it another spin uh just
because i like it um
a lot and we actually created a
sculpture of this that is
hanging out in our lab and if you ever
come and visit
george mason in northern virginia you
can come and visit the sculpture we we
we called it mental floss so the beauty
of this framework is not only that the
identity of the neurons
give us the connectivity of the network
but they also give us
information like the distance along the
path of the axon
and that basically defines delays of the
signals and also
probability of failure of spike
transmission and also the distance along
the dendrites
which if you remember your neuroscience
basics actually affects the size of the
signal integrated at the soma as well as
the duration of the signal at the soma
so uh let's see where we are
um how are we doing with time uh 12 35
would you mind starting the poll um i'll
ask you guys a question
um in uh in the in the poll
uh we we basically can use the next 15
minutes or so
in one of two ways one is we continue
with the traditional slide talk in the
lecture
and i can show you a little bit of the
math and the theory
that is linking that are linking
morphology and connectivity and the
identity of neuron types to network
connectivity so a little bit of the
quantification and the mathematical
framework on that
the second possibility is that we switch
out of the slides
i turn on my browser and i'll navigate
with you i'll show you a demo
of the hippocamp.org framework this is
something you can also do on your own
but i can show you some features of that
and help you
understand what the various functions
and tabs are and either of those would
take about 10 minutes or so there will
be plenty of questions
plenty of time for questions and
discussion at the end
so please vote ahead the poll is in
progress
uh will be a democratic group
i don't have a horse in the race i'm
happy to go either way
but please vote away whether you prefer
option one continuing slides with math
and q
in theory or option two hands-on live
web browsing demo and while we'll leave
maybe a minute or so so that people can
vote
uh jack is there any question that you'd
like to for me to take on while we wait
for
for the voting to take place um
certainly
so there is a question um that's uh we
have a one of our
participants is asking um how does your
definition
for a neuron um work for in development
neuron connections are not static
there's lots of pruning migration and
morphological changes
the definition that you provided seems
to
uh like that it seems like it might not
give
a static identity to individual neurons
across development and circuit formation
it's a fantastic question i want to
command the person who asked this
question because it's a very insightful
question
indeed there is a lot of change during
development especially early development
we track that in the hippocampus it's a
very interesting question we had to ask
at the get-go because it affects
the foundation of what we're doing we
discover that there is a lot of change
in the first two weeks
of age for rodents specifically rats
mice and guinea pigs for which there is
enough data to determine this
and relatively less change
at the level of axonal and hydridic
patterns
after the second week of age so we
decided to
focus our research on the adult
hippocampus or what we call young adult
which is a dollar cent hippocampus
which is from age 14 and older
and of course the hippocampus is one of
those regions where there is a lot of
adult plasticity
there are neuron types that continue to
be added to the hippocampal formation
specifically to the dental jars
throughout lifetime
in mammals both rodents and and primates
and humans
but uh we account for those but other
than that the identity of the neuron
types after the second week of
development
is fairly static it is possible in
principle to create this framework for
earlier development and say postnatal
development the first week of that
it would be a different knowledge base
though but it's a really excellent
question
one other question hopefully you can uh
address quite quickly
is um can you elaborate a little bit
more on the uh
type of differential equations you were
referring to
absolutely yes it's i call the easy
caveat model
the basic uh structure of the model has
just four differential equations
it's a phenomenological model of spiking
activity which uses a framework so
called up hop
bifurcations um the four parameters are
basically defining
whether the periodicity of the firing
which is the dynamical system where
you're having
a jump at the point of spikes
and then a recovery to resting
uh whether that's a supercritical event
or not
and uh the basic model has uh
four parameters and it defines uh the
entirety of the dynamics
which can basically be categorized in
hops bifurcation type one or type two
and that's basically continue spiking or
bursting
uh however we use a slightly more
complete version of the model which is a
so-called
nine parameter echevich model which on
top of the bifurcation representation
by bifurcation i mean dynamical
bifurcation in this case is not
morphological bifurcation
uh it has uh biophysics that include the
height of the spike
and the capacitance uh so so it affects
a little bit of the subthreshold
signals and so forth so i can i can
show you it seems like uh the voting is
is stable now there is a two-thirds
majority for hands-on live web browsing
demo so i'll show you
an example of that easy cabinet model
and i'll show you the
the uh the links to the actual evidence
for the models
and hopefully that will help answer the
question as well
so uh because we are going to skip over
the math
before we go on to the hands-on
live browsing demo i will be remiss if i
did not
acknowledge um the many
constituents that really deserve
acknowledgement
on the top of the slide are the funding
agencies that have been supporting
this work and many other lines of
investigation
in my lab really the lion's share goes
to the national institute of health
in green are current lines of funding
and i am incredibly grateful to the
national institute of neural disorder
and stroke and india's
and the national institute of mental
health and image
also non-profit foundations and private
corporations
including the melton foundation and
northum grandma which were instrumental
at the very get-go when hippocampal was
bought an idea and it really was not
deserving of a full nih grant
they provided the seed money to to get
it started
and in yellow here are many other
previous funders that had
a contribution especially in the early
days
of constructing this knowledge base and
perhaps the most important aspect here
is this
uh bottom part which are all the people
who
are contributing and have contributed in
my lab to this effort
including post-docs the leader of the
hippocampal project
in my lab is research associate
professor d wheeler
and several other people have
contributed tremendously shari's wise
charism white to the molecular
phenotypic alexander commandant of
to the firing pattern uh carina tequato
to the probabilities of connections
kevin moradi
to the synaptic activity david hamilton
to the neuroinformatics framework
and among the phd students siva
venkadesh
who is actually now a postdoc at
university of virginia
in jack's lab created the modeling for
the izukewicz
work and filled out all the data for all
the neuron types for the azikiah
patterns
and nate saturn is working on the
functions
and jeff copsich on the simulations so
these are
just among the people i should mention
also
mantua tilly is actually uh creating the
data for the counts of neurons
of each type so it's really a broad
group
and the the merit for
what's been done is really theirs i'm
here just to
do public relations and advertisement of
this
okay so let me get out of the slides if
i'm able to
i think i have to stop share here and
let's see if i can
share my chrome
all right can you see my chrome or my
web browser you can really do this in
any
browser yes we can see it i like chrome
but other people use firefox or
or um safari
or really anything so this is
hippocampum.org you can just type
peoplecampon.org
and uh the main view of the neurons
is uh this morph morphology matrix which
i described so these are neuron types
and these are representations of
dendrites and axons in the various
uh uh parcels and if you click
on the name of a neuron you're brought
into the neuron page
uh where you're given the formal name
and synonyms
and then um uh
articles that um the information was
was gathered from and in this case this
is a pretty famous neuron type there are
many articles
uh and there and their uh
bibliographic information um
and then the definition of the
morphology so for example this says that
the axons of these cells
are in a given layer a representative
figure
the molecular marker that are expressed
or positive
and that are known not to be expressed
or negative
uh the ones that are mixed expression
depending on which
technique you use and then
electrophysiological properties
there are annotated notes if there are
any uh to explain that
the firing patterns for that neuron type
and the easy cavity model parameters
so this is what i was describing before
in my uh
in my answer these are the parameters of
these akivic models
for that and in in this particular case
for example we can take this particular
phenotype of the neuron
and and say that we want to simulate it
using these models
and so we can say what happens for
example if we
inject i don't know 400 pico amps
starting from
25 milliseconds and going on for
let's say 200 milliseconds and so
uh so this is a very nice quick
framework because it allows to
in real time this is just running on the
server
create a simulated spiking model that
reflects what is known about the
experimental data
for this and
it also if you keep scrolling down in
the page
uh you get well computer biophysical
computational models
uh for that cell but also potential
connections into the circuit
one of the latest addition to this has
been uh the in vivo data so what is
known about the activity of these
neurons in vivo
including the phase from the theta uh
and uh
sharp wave ratios for those
and one thing i want to say is that for
any piece of
information that you see here any piece
of information
you actually have annotated evidence so
for example if we say
i want to know why it is that you say
that the axons of these neurons and
stratum lucidum
we annotate that evidence so we can say
open all the evidence
and this is excerpts from articles that
have been
mined into the literature using a pretty
complex
way using in this case information since
it's anatomical piece of knowledge
from histology and so forth and you can
go all the way to electromicroscopy
evidence
and of course the corresponding text
and uh i think this is my buzz telling
me
that i am 15 minutes to the mark which
is good i think we're doing well with
time
uh but uh but also with the
corresponding link
and the uh and the actual quote uh in
this case
uh to interpret that and uh
so if we go now to for example
since you asked about the model
specifically
uh i'll highlight that uh so we can go
to easycavitch models
each of these tabs really provides
a matrix of information for all the
neuron types and these are the
parameters
like i mentioned it's possible to
consider these neurons as
point cells or single compartments or
multi-compartments
and if you go to the multi-compartment
option of course this table becomes much
longer because you have nine parameters
for each compartment
depending on however however many there
are
and again for uh for um
each of these parameters
there is underlying evidence and you can
also download directly the
the modeling the simulation scripts and
the whole set of parameters from the
neuron page
and uh these parameters are fitted
using information on the firing patterns
so this is a firing pattern matrix that
says for each neuron type
what kind of patterns are uh
absurd for example asp stands for
adaptive spiking
and d nast stand for delayed
non-adopted spiking and so forth and
these are the
pieces of uh the number of phenotypes
distinct phenotypes for that that are
that are annotated the problem with
physiology is that of course it's
condition dependent
so if you want to look at
firing patterns you can navigate by
firing pattern
but you really have to
look at the specific details of in this
case the stimulation
for example how many milliseconds the
stimulation lasted and how much current
was injected to elicit that particular
pattern
and then parameters you such as kind of
scroll
sorry the commands of the zooms are in
the way so you'll see my
cursor being a little bit jerky but the
parameters of the firing
are also annotated here as well
so i can i can go on there are many many
different functionalities that one can
browse including
uh i mentioned synaptic probabilities uh
and uh live uh phase locking
uh and so forth so in the synaptic
probability you can look at
the actual probability of connection or
the number of contacts
or the dendritic axonal length or the
somatic distances
along the presynaptic and postsynaptic
cells and you can download in all cases
you can always download
the spreadsheet and and do as you as you
see fit
with that and there are tools where you
can calculate
the the parameters even changing
some arbitrary choices like thresholds
and so forth
and you can also search the knowledge
base both in terms of neuron types
neuron properties
literature etc so for example
let's say that you're in the lab and you
discover or observe a neuron that has
certain properties and you wonder if
there are neurons that are known with
those
characteristics so for example let's say
that
you find a neuron that has axons in the
stratum lacunas molecular
of ca1 and let's say expresses
i don't know um
particular biomarkers like somatostatin
and
i don't know and we can say
has as a pre-synaptic input potentially
from
let's say say one pyramidal cell because
let's say that you were
uh doing a pair recording
right and now you find out there are two
possible match
of those the c1 by projection cells and
they say one performing pathway
associated
quadrilateral cells and
and then you can say for example give me
the electrophysiology parameters for all
of those or of course go directly to
those neurons
and see everything and again remember
for each of those
you always have a link to the evidence
page
so you always know that where this was
recorded and in what conditions and so
forth
and maybe the very last thing which is
the last one we added
the paper was accepted in plos biology
uh just about a month ago with the in
vivo recording so
this is a the latest addition to
hippocampus
for now and uh that's basically
information on the phase locking
of particular cells again this is uh
this is now live and in vivo so it
depends on the behavior
whether animal is awake or sleep or
anesthetized
and which type of recording was done and
of course
other metadata like the age of the
animal the sex
the species itself whether it's a rat or
a mouse etc
and uh and then for example if we
are claiming that let's say uh ca one
exact sonic cells have
have a phase locking of 45 degrees uh
to the theta rhythm and we are
interested in understanding why
um you can now load
oops it looks like a great um
all right it was a little bit slow there
uh
but um but you can then um
still load there is a lot of evidence
here no
um okay there we go
uh you can actually see in this
particular case the papers and the
evidence for that information
so i think i'll stop here i hope that
i've given you
an overview of this but if there are
requests for
what to look at into the database or any
other questions at this point
i hope i provided you an overview a
data-driven overview
of the relationship between the
morphology of neurons
the classification or the identity of
the neuron types and the connectivity of
the network
if i succeeded even only partially on
that
i would have said that was the goal of
the talk so i'll stop here
take questions or request for additional
information navigation
giorgio thank you so very much that was
uh fantastic to have
a live in action demo as part of your
your lecture
it's exciting to kind of see it in
action and as you're going through that
i couldn't help but think back to the
days of coco mac
being you know one of the driving forces
of this and i know that you had
some uh some contributions to that um
some of the
our audience members and it may not be
that old as old as you and i
who would remember that maybe you could
like give a little synopsis of
maybe uh uh what that was about and
maybe how that plus other things like
some of the work of say you know david
van essen and
and in the famous uh fellman and vanessa
and paper and some of these other things
maybe have given some inspiration
to the hippocampus
indeed indeed and uh in fact many of
these ideas came from
discussions uh in the early days
uh and i have to say i've i've known
jack for a long time but uh but we did
meet
over the 30 days of the so-called human
brain project now people these days
associate the human brain project the
european effort
but there was back in the days like the
state the previous millennium
before color television right yeah well
not quite i don't know if
it was there but uh but i mean already
saying previous millennium should
impress the students these days uh and
there was a human brain project that was
launched by the nation's
health uh in the us and uh
and it was with discussions exactly from
uh
people like david vanessa and the late
ralph carter who did noncomac
and many others including
uh some of uh jack's uh
earlier mentors uh including artoga at
ucla
and then usc and mike azanega
who was at darwood now university of
santa barbara and
many of those discussions influenced the
vision
and also in the end the implementation
for this framework
you know and it's interesting with with
connectivity and
some of the work that was say
spearheaded by you and others in those
early days
um really kind of led to what became
kind of some of the basis for
an understanding of the human connectome
and its embodiment in the human
connectome project and now of course
we're seeing that
have multiple derivatives uh it's uh
extension into the um adolescent brain
and cognitive development
study or the abcd study and in europe
and these very large-scale
uk biobank kind of things in human data
um
but certainly inspired by work that was
done in the laboratory animal
in macaques and in mice in this case um
so it's like
connectivity is is fundamentally
important and
obviously looking at what's connected to
what in the hippocampus
is vitally important one of our
participants asked do you also
incorporate axoxonic and axosomatic
uh synapses as well yeah i
i for for shortness of communication i
talked about
axons and dendrites as the
quintessential and most abundant
outputs and inputs of neurons there are
exceptions there in the hippocampus
there are no exceptions on the output
all the outputs are actions in other
brain regions there are exceptions there
too for example in the olfactory bulb
there are synapses where the dendrite
can be a presynaptic entity
and and be the output but in the
hippocampus the output is a very
fairly firm rule but the input does vary
for example
a chandelier cells or exact sonic cells
contact the external initial segment of
their targets
and basket cells contact the cell body
stoma of their target and we do annotate
that that was part of the
you know maybe a little too quickly one
of the slides when i put in
specificity there we do annotate those
then we
update the rules of connectivity uh
based on those so if the
if the presynaptic type is an exact
sonic then it will look for external
initial segments
for partners and not dendrites for
partners and there is also some
specificity some specificity that is
known for example axoxonic cells
only target the exponential segment of
glutamatergic partner
so they tend to avoid gabaergic cells as
far as we know at least in the
hippocampus
and uh in contrast there are some
gabaergic tiles called
interneuron specific interneurons that
specifically target
other gabaergic cells and so they they
work as this inhibitor
of the network and so we we do write
those rules in
and the engine that calculates the
connection in real time on the server
will make sure that if he finds a
potential connection in principle
between
an interneuron specific interneuron and
the pyramidal style
it will discard it so the most attentive
of you might have stain in matrixes
there will be red crosses
occasionally those are the symbol
meaning that even if there is a
potential connection there
the experimental evidence bars us from
using it
in the circuit interesting i mean as if
i need to ask
what do you feel is the role for data
scientists and computational modeling
and kind of databasing experts in this
field of neuroscience uh
as we've now now in the second decade of
the the new millennium
uh what what's needed in this space
uh a lot i would say um so there is
tremendous
uh need and also tremendous opportunity
i would say
let me start by saying neuroscience is
changing it used to be exclusively the
purview of small labs around the world
some lab smaller than others some labs
large but but always funded by
one or two or three are ones but
but that was basically the extent of it
uh in the past
15 years we've seen institutions uh
coming up like the allen institute
in seattle or the janelia research
campus of howard hughes
in ashford virginia uh and uh
more recently others like the zuckerberg
foundation for self-phenotyping and so
forth
and those are really industrialized
effort right there is an
industrialization of neuroscience that
looks a little bit more like uh
cyclotrons didn't visit
uh right in in uh or or large efforts
international efforts to
collect for example astronomical
information that require large machinery
satellite launches etc and all the kinds
of things that a single lab can do
but that accumulate then a lot of data
that is distributed through a network
of collaborators and scientists so there
is a lot of
need an opportunity both for data
annotators and
domain expertise who can uh add value
of the information uh with what is known
uh in the field
but also data scientists to take
advantage of those and to create
knowledge out of the data which is
always very different right you can have
a lot of bits out there
but you then need to connect the dots
and find those regularities
very much like the early chemist found
those regularity
starting from the observations of the
beginning of chemistry which is
lavoisier
right so the fact that the observations
that uh
elements and molecules were combined in
fixed ratios that was the key
insight that led to the periodic table
and to modern chemistry
and the same is going to happen in
neuroscience i would say is happening we
are in the mid
of that transition in neuroscience where
we are now accumulating data in an
industrial way
and we are connecting the dots the
principles in my mind
are going to for sure require an
analysis of connectivity
because the brain is ultimately a
gigantic network and that's the
quintessential aspect of it
but other people might have different
intuitions and and different
quests to pursue but the role of data
scientists in those is going to be huge
george osgoly from george mason
university thank you so much for sharing
your
work with us your your live demo of
of things in action uh and your vision
for
uh for this field uh super excited to
have you as our final
speaker in this series uh thank you very
much and i want to thank all of our
participants for
for joining us um on our uh series uh
this concludes our series but uh we'll
be seeing all of our participants um
at our subsequent activities uh through
our micro labs and
eventually uh at our um uh biomedical
data science innovation lab uh next
month
so uh once again thank you everybody
enjoy your weekend
thank you jack goodbye